So, what are the consequences of something
being placed under pressure? Well, if I look
at this balloon, I can apply pressure to it by
exerting a force over its area. And when I do,
well, the balloon actually gets a little bit
smaller. The air inside the balloon gets a
little more densely packed together. And
in fact, this is exactly what happens on earth.
Out here, far away from the surface of the
earth, there are not very many air molecules.
This is a low pressure environment and
with nothing to weigh down on these air
molecules from above, they’re basically
free to play. They are free to move around.
Now below this outer layer of the
atmosphere, where all these air molecules
are sort of weighing on the atoms below it,
the molecules below it, and so these become
a little more densely packed. And as we go
even further down towards the surface of
the earth, where us humans tend to live,
the air gets even more densely packed.
And so we see that down near the surface
of the earth, where we have high pressure,
we also have a high density of air molecules.
And this high density of air molecules makes
us humans living at the surface very happy.
So I want to know, why do humans like high
pressure so much? Maybe the weight from
all that air above us keeps us from growing
too tall. Maybe air pollution tends to go to
regions of low pressure. Or maybe it means
that there’s lots of oxygen for us to breathe.
Go ahead and choose the best answer.